[Music]
the perfect sports car should combine
sexy good looks with nimble steering
aggressive power and a high-quality
cabin it will be expensive but not so
frankly that it's out of reach for
everyone
Porsche Mercedes and Jaguar have three
of the top sports cars on offer today
but which is the best for you
let's get the numbers out of the way all
three cars have impressive steps the
Porsches come just slightly behind the
bends in the Jag but each is a thrill to
drive in its own way this is the 2017
Porsche 911 Carrera Cabriolet the engine
in this is a 420 horsepower 6-cylinder
boxer engine mounted in the rear this is
Force's famous engine it's difficult to
describe the feeling when you get behind
the wheel this is where that mystical
Porsche x-factor comes in the rear-wheel
drive on 20-inch Carrera s wheels and
Porsche torque vectoring grip the road
better than any other model in our group
the AMG GTS is faster and more fun to
drive in any other Mercedes I think it
feels like a rocketship
this car has a lot to offer it has that
amazing v8 engine it has the horsepower
it has the torque of course if you're
not careful the rear-wheel drive
AMG will fishtail forward with a mind of
its own that said it's amazing in a
straight line
this is the two-door coupe Jaguar
debuted in 2015 as a way to get back in
the game and the company did it with
flying colors the handling is great I
mean this car is so perfectly balanced
it's really a treat to drive especially
on winding roads the torque that you
feel when you drive it is the most
impressive of the group but it's not as
connected to the road as a 911 nor as
smooth as the AMG it is tight when it
comes to steering and braking this is
Mercedes bad-boy halo car meant to
recall the glorious going SL that
Mercedes made in the 1960s the idea is
that it's sexy Elora will attract young
new fans to the brand this is the car
you want to get to make a really loud
statement the Jag is all muscles and
roar punched up at the seams like a
football player if you kind of like a
hunky mass of metal and gears under your
foot this one is the car for you the 911
is eminently recognizable yet after all
these years it's still impressive the
front end is flirtatious the rear is
muscle East and the headlights are
friendly
[Music]
there is plenty to see inside the Jaguar
lots of loud blue stitching performance
seats and even a handle for the front
passenger to hold on to for dear life
this is the least well done of our three
when it comes to interior quality and
design but it's still pretty great
Porsche was the first sporting brand to
introduce the PDK paddle shift
technology which is quicker and better
for city driving than the manual there
is also a back seat in this option
something the other two don't have now I
don't know please put anybody in that
back seat except for maybe your dog or
someone you don't like but it is back
there you can use it at pinch inside I
loved how the Mercedes look it has crazy
octopus-like round dials all the way
through the center and the dash and
everything felt thick and rich the
bottom line you can't go wrong with any
of these incredible machines but if you
want the whole package at the best value
the 911 is the clear winner
sure it's not as aggressive looking at
the AMG and it has less power than the
jack but it's incredible connection to
the ground
it's cozy perfect German handling its
superior suspension and it's minimal but
quality interior mean the 911 Carrera S
Cabriolet is more than stands its ground
[Music]
you